hi everyone thanks for joining us today
my name is sarah schuett and i'm a flow
cytometry specialist
with milt tinney biotech and today i'm
going to talk to you
about the mats quant vibe flow cytometer
and its benefits it's going to be
the perfect instrument for any labs
utilizing fluorescent protein reporters
fruit dyes or for labs that simply want
to use pe and 50 conjugates together and
not worry about as much compensation
issues
so to get us started i'm going to talk
about the agenda we're going to address
today we're going to dive into the
optics of
the maxquant vibe and the small
footprint of the instrument we're going
to talk about the automation of the
system our technical support and
hands-on training that we provide to our
customers i'm going to give you a few
real-world examples of people using the
vibe for the research and then i'm going
to summarize everything for you
so to get us started
the benefit of the vibe is going to be
the yellow laser you can see on the left
hand side we have the violet which is
the 405 nanometer laser the yellow which
is the 561 nanometer laser and the blue
which is the 488 nanometer laser and
together those allow us to analyze
multiple fluorescent proteins at once
the vibe incorporates
all of these
together to come up with 10 detection
channels eight of those are going to be
fluorescent channels it's going to give
us optimal pe sensitivity and reliable
apc detection on a benchtop flow
cytometer
the benefit of the 561 nanometer laser
is that we're optimally exciting the pe
die you can see here we have an
excitation and emission graph of
the pe signal and so we are
optimally exciting the pe and collecting
its emission another benefit here is
that we spatially separate our lasers on
the max quant vibe where we're exciting
the gfp or fitzy off the blue laser the
pe off the yellow laser you can see here
on the top diagram
we can see the separation between those
two on the bottom diagram that
represents what most bench sides flow
cytometers implement which is fitzy and
pe both excited from the blue laser it
introduces some compensation issues that
we don't want to have to worry about as
a researcher
another benefit of our optical bench on
the max quant vibe is that we can
simultaneously detect multiple
fluorescent proteins at once
here are histograms of the cho cells
that have been infected transfected with
cfp egfp
yfp and cherry mk2 and pi and you can
see how easily we can differentiate
these signals and how
bright and easily identifiable these
populations are going to be
the next thing we're going to talk about
for the vibe is automation and so before
we dive into the automation of the
system i really want to bring up why
automation is important in flow
cytometry we are all used to having
automation in our day-to-day lives now
with the implementation of these home
assistants that allow us to control the
temperature of our homes or play music
on demand but why is automation so
important in flow cytometry
and so there was a study done in 2015
that showed that 50 of preclinical
research was not able to be reproduced
and that's why automation is so
important if you look at the figures
here it shows that 28 billion dollars
worth of research in the us per year is
not able to be reproduced
so automation is going to help us
improve the reproducibility of our
assays it's also going to increase our
efficiency and gives us hands-on and
reduce the amount of hands-on time that
we're implementing into these workflows
it's going to allow us to standardize
our assays within the same flow
cytometer but also across multiple flow
cytometers
so when we talk about automation and
flow cytometry what do we mean and it's
simple we're talking about automating
your entire workflow from start to
finish and this is the true benefit of
the max quant vibe we're talking about
automating from calibration all the way
down to the custom express modes which
is our data analysis and i'm going to
walk through how each one of these steps
of the process can be automated using
the vibe but this is where we're going
to have a benefit over other flow
cytometers in the market we're going to
be able to help you increase your
reproducibility and reduce your hands-on
time required so to get us started we're
going to look at our simple and easy
calibrations you can see from this video
a user scanned our calibration beads put
a drop of beads into a tube the robotic
needle arm is going to come out and
dilute that sample
pipette makes it up and down and then
take a sample for acquisition
the software is going to launch our
automated qc program
and we're going to be able to qc the
instrument
for the day
now the only human intervention in this
process is putting a drop of beads into
a tube and selecting start calibration
on the touch screen
really the heart of this system is this
robotic arm that you saw in the previous
video and so this robotic needle arm is
going to allow us to eliminate errors
the max quant vibe is a syringe pump
fluidic-based system it's going to allow
us to enable volumetric counts with
precision we're going to be able to
grab volumes as little as 25 microliters
we're not going to have to worry about
any specific tubes to run our assays in
because we're not a pressure-based
system
our carryover between samples remains at
an industry low of 0.01 percent and this
robotic needle arm is going to ensure
that we're mixing our samples properly
before acquisition
because the robotic needle arm is going
to mix in a pipette action just like a
human
and that's going to ensure that our
samples are properly mixed and we get
accurate and precise
measuring of our samples
talked a little bit about the cell
counting but if you're looking to use
the vibe for cell counting all it takes
is three easy steps you're going to
place up to 96 samples on the rack
you're going to instruct the vibe how
much volume you're going to take out of
each sample and then you're going to
press start we don't have to worry about
spiking any of these samples with
counting beads
you can see on the right hand side of
the screen we did do a dilution series
and the max plot vibe is extremely
linear over a large dynamic range and
then we also did a comparison study
between different cell counters on the
market and you can see that the cvs for
the maxqua analyzer are extremely low we
can do robust and reliable cell counts
on this instrument
we also offer versatile sample
processing so you can see that first
image we have our chill 5 and our chill
96 the chill 5 is going to hold 24 fax
tubes and the chill 96 is going to hold
any standard
96 well plate that's available on the
market they're called chill because both
of them are going to freeze at four
degrees so that means you can
temperature control your samples
throughout your one run to ensure sample
viability
we also have our single tube holder in
the middle there of that picture that's
going to hold a fax tube or an eppendorf
tube and then on the right hand side we
have our universal reagent rack that can
hold 5 ml glass vials and 1 ml plastic
files and i'll show you the auto
labeling feature in the next slide
the benefit of the auto labeling is that
we're going to minimize human operator
error you can see from the video that
the robotic needle arm came out took a
specified volume from our 5 ml tube
added it to a specific well on a plate
did pipette mixing and then took the
sample to the instrument for acquisition
so we can use this to add reagents to
our samples if we're looking to do a
live dead cell marker we can use our
viability dye here we can also use it
for antibody staining we can also even
use it to dilute our sample everything
about this process is going to be
programmable so we can program the time
of incubation if we need to we can also
program the tighter and then i did
mention carryover earlier but we do have
a wasp wash station that's part of the
instrument it's going to wash the needle
on the inside and the outside and it's
going to allow us to remain at point
zero one percent carryover per sample
which is an industry low
so i talked about standardization of
qc and sample acquisition but what about
once we get into data analysis and so on
the screen you'll see two different
samples and they both
exhibit sample to sample variation and
this is something that's very common in
flow cytometry you can see the gate that
we applied to the first sample on the
top doesn't make sense on the bottom
sample so what about a system that
if you had a system that would recognize
that this gate was in the wrong way okay
but what if you had a system that would
take it a step further recognizing that
the gate was placed incorrectly but then
also moving that gate
and setting it at an appropriate place
and this is what we can do on the max
quant vibe with our express modes so
express modes are going to offer a
robust and standardized way to set up
your instrument to do your sample
measurement and then also to do your
data analysis and all of this is going
to happen at the push of a button
so express modes are going to be
automated
reliable and simple
and basically what we do is we have a
predefined experiment set up including
acquisition and analysis settings
and we're going to machine learn the
data in order to apply algorithm-based
gating
so that it makes sense for your data set
and it's going to be automatically
adjusted for each data file to achieve
optimal results there's no human
intervention there's no guesswork all of
this is going to be driven with
mathematics
so an example of an express mode is
frets so if anyone is doing fret
analysis you're measuring the protein to
protein interactions this requires an
unstained blank an acceptor only and a
donor only sample and then at least one
fret sample
and the software is going to do
automatic gating it's going to generate
all of your dot plots it's going to look
at your intensity histograms it's going
to look at your median intensities and
it's going to take all of this
information and compile it together and
do automatic fret calculations and
that's what you'll see here on the right
hand side of the screen this is the
screenshot from the max quantify
software where we ran the fret express
mode and you can see that it breaks it
down between the different samples that
we ran and then at the very bottom it
actually calculated the fret efficiency
median so no longer are we having to run
our assay and then export all of our
data into excel to do further downstream
analysis the express modes can do this
all for us
automatically and we're not having to
introduce human error into
this process at all
so let's say that you're doing something
that's not fred and you still are really
interested in an express mode
and that's where we can start and build
you a custom express mode so i have
these images of the qc and the auto
labeling and also a screenshot of the
express mode to show you that if you
implement an express mode or a custom
express mode on your instrument every
step of the process now is going to be
automated we can build an express mode
around your assay and your needs we can
use that to generate a report by a max
quantify software that's going to have
all of the necessary information related
to your assay this is going to increase
reproducibility and it's going to
automate your entire process
so i talked about data harmonization but
is that possible without looking at
instrument harmonization the express
modes will help us to address the issue
by providing automated data analysis to
increase reproducibility but is that the
only consideration we need to think
about and the answer to that is no we
need to look at a way to assure intra
instrument performance as well as inter
instrument performance
there are a lot of factors that go into
that but from our side we have
implemented what we call smart gain
technology to help this process
smartgate technology is a universal
setup that's going to ensure consistency
across longitudinal and collaborative
studies
we use beads with a known medium
fluorescence intensity to help harmonize
instrument settings which allow us to
standardize flow assays across multiple
instruments this is going to work from
test to test from user to user from
instrument to instrument and across
sites globally the smart gain technology
is going to give you consistency that
you can count on
as far as support we are here for you to
support your work and your assays with
the vibe you get maxquat live support
which is going to connect you with a phd
level scientist 24 5 to help you with
any questions that you may have we also
have technical and field application
support to help you with assay design
custom automation and express mode
development and then we also do offer
hands-on training at our miltoni biotech
facilities
so i talked about how i'm going to
present some people who are using the
vibe in their research let's talk about
how
labs are using the vibe today
the first example is a group out of
stanford
engineering dynamic cell control with
synthetic small molecule responsive rna
devices and this group needed a way to
easily and reversibly control the cell
cycle
they suggested that a better
understanding
and control of the cycle
may aid in more effective cell
reprogramming the current methods relied
on small molecule inhibitors or nutrient
deprivation methods and these approaches
can present a number of drawbacks
the group proposed using ribosome-based
gene control devices to address the
drawbacks
these genetic cell cycle controllers are
able to inducibly and reversibly arrest
up to 80 percent of the cell population
in a chosen phase of the cell cycle and
perform reliably over multiple
experiments over a time frame of several
weeks
so the way that they used the vibe in
this process was to actually look at the
dna content so in the schematic on the
right hand side of the screen you can
see their process where they are seated
in dishes grown for three days then
they're collecting their cells they're
permalizing them and then they're
staining them for dna content they get
run on the vibe where they gate them for
cells using forward and side scatter
then they look at only their single
cells and then they look at their dna
content and they analyze which phase of
the cell cycle these cells are in
they also had a protocol with transient
infections that you can see is included
in the brackets so if they did the
transfections they actually gated for
their gfp and then looked at the cell
cycle for those gfp positive cells
and so their conclusion was the first
time synthetic rna devices have been
used to control the mammalian cell cycle
these rna platform represents a general
class of synthetic biology tools for
modular dynamic and multi-output control
over mammalian cells
the next group
that's using the vive is focused on
developing a fast economical and high
throughput platform to study chromatin
biology
and so they are studying yeast and so
the way that they use the vibe in their
study
was to process 96 well plates of freshly
induced yeast cultures for antibody
labeling
the vibe was used to detect histones
screen antibodies and for the mapping
and binary crosstalk experiments and you
can see what their conclusion was after
using the vibe for their research it's
on the screen
and then the final example i'm going to
talk today is a group out of singapore
that was looking at p pastorius as a
widely considered industrial workhorse
for recombinant protein production
however genomic integration has a
relatively low transformation efficiency
and some heterogeneity due to random
integration so what they ended up doing
was transfecting yeast with blue
fluorescent protein or bfp expressing
plasmids and then they cultured
then they ran those cells on the vibe
so they analyzed these samples in 96
well plates and they mapped out
blue fluorescent and protein intensities
on heat maps and they did hierarchical
clustering based on the relative
frequencies of fluorescent events in
each gate
so you can see their conclusion here and
how well the vibe worked for what they
were trying to accomplish
here's just a slide about what our
customers are saying
i really like how people refer to the
vibe as something fast rapid and fully
automated
and
how it's very easy to use
so just to summarize it if you had to
listen to this presentation and come
away with four things these are the four
things that i really want you to focus
on the walk away capabilities of the
vibe how you can just load in your
samples import your experiment settings
and leave the staining data acquisition
and the data analysis to the vibe
we can do easy fluorescent protein
analysis because we have
the violet blue and yellow lasers we can
look at fluorescent protein and reporter
applications using mcherry gfp cfp and
many more
we have the flexible assay setup meaning
that we can easily and immediately
switch between our tubes and our plates
we don't have to worry about hooking up
any clunky hts to our system everything
is just going to be placed on the rack
right in front of the instrument and
then the multi-instrument alignment we
can harmonize data with collaborating
labs to ensure the reproducibility of
your assay
thank you sarah for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started
sarah um thank you so much the first
question is
can this equipment fit into a biosafety
cabinet
awesome thanks serena yeah this is a
very compact instrument so it's just
over two feet wide
and then the depth and the height are
just below two feet so it fits perfectly
in a bio safety cabinet and we have
customers who currently have it in a
biosafety cabinet working with microbes
human samples or animal products
fantastic the second question is
can you tell me how the integrated
column works for cell enrichment
yeah so our max quant vibe actually has
an integrated maps column on the system
and so that can be used for automatic
pre-enrichment of rare cell populations
prior to flow cytometry analysis it's
going to follow the same principle as
our traditional max column so briefly
you're going to label your target cells
magnetically with our max micro beads
and then you're going to stain with the
appropriate antibody conjugated
fluorochromes
these label cells are going to be taken
up by the max quant and then passed over
the column the magnetically labeled
cells are retained while the negative
cells pass through the column and then
go directly to the waste container the
magnetically labeled cells are then
washed and eluded and then passed to the
flow cytometer for analysis
fantastic
the third question we have i have a
small sample
i have small sample volumes what is the
minimum sample volume needed for
analysis
yeah so because we have the
the syringe pump driven system uh we can
go as low as 25 microliters that's the
minimum recommended volume for analysis
fantastic
my lab wants to start using a flow
photometer for analysis can you please
tell me more about this training and
science support
yeah so that's one of the the big values
that we offer here at mel tinney so we
have uh hands-on trainings at our
miltoni locations but then we can also
do the real time support with our max
quant live support that's going to
connect you with a phd level scientist
and that's available 24 5 and then we
also have a field application team that
will offer training on site in your lab
and help you develop any flow panels
then if you would like to move forward
with a custom application development we
do have an additional team that's there
to support any application needs that
you may have
very good well thank you again sarah for
your time today and your important
research before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsors
miltoni biotech for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years till 9 29 23 and labyrinths
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
goodbye